the 2019 Women's World Cup kicks off
today in France celebrating a huge rise
in popularity for women's soccer
organizers expect to attract 1 billion
TV viewers around the world that's 25
percent more than the 2015 tournament
won by Team USA Roxana Saberi is in
Paris where the opening ceremony begins
in a few hours Roxana we mentioned the
TV audience do they expect a big crowd
there as well they do Dana the stadium
holds about 50,000 people and all the
tickets were the first game here were
sold out within about 48 hours as
women's soccer has become more popular
it's also become a lot more competitive
but players on the US team told us
they're ready they're heading here today
from England where they've been focused
on the field 15 miles from the heart of
London America's top female soccer
players tuck themselves away for 10 days
to train and come together as a team we
all want to obviously gone and hopefully
win this World Cup but here training
it's about just bringing out the best in
ourselves this year's World Cup will be
the first for crystal Dunn the third for
co-captain Megan Rapinoe this one I feel
like I have so much left to prove
winning the last one seems so far away
and it was such a different team these
women are all familiar with one another
for years they've played together in
different leagues across the u.s. now
with a mix of new and veteran players
this team hopes to win America's fourth
Women's World Cup team USA first lifted
the trophy in 1991 but it was this tense
shootout in 1999 that captivated America
and Brandi Chastain led the team to
victory
turning players into stars skeptics into
supporters
but 2015 the final between the u.s. and
Japan became the most-watched soccer
game women's or men's in US history to
win this year the US will have to be
tougher competition than ever like teams
from Germany England and host nation
France but win or lose it won't defeat
America's growing love for the sport an
estimated two million girls across the
United States now play high school
senior Julia Dole turns out a soccer
academy in New York if I'll be in the
next Women's World Cup that's my dream
the people playing at this World Cup you
know they're all inspirations because
they've pushed the sports and ways that
we can't even imagine how do you hope to
inspire the next generation of women
players it's about just stepping on the
pitch and being like I want to win this
game and I'm gonna do whatever it takes
it's about getting really like grinding
through these games and just being that
last team standing off the field the US
team is also facing some challenges 28
players have sued the US soccer alleging
gender discrimination they're also
calling for the same prize money that
the men get at their World Cup we'll
have more on that battle next week as
the u.s. gears up for its first game of
the tournament Tony all right Roxanna in
Paris for us Roxanna enjoy your time
there and we're gonna enjoy watching
those girls play and [ __ ] Roxanna
raised a good point in it we have to do
something about the disparity in the pay
between the men and the women especially
when you see how many people are
watching the women and they are
champions they win double that payout
for them the World Cup scale but still
yes that's equal pay especially when you
are the ones that are winning here in
the US compared to the men's team we're
a cheer in awhile